yeah hello one welcome to the 30 playing
volley from India what is he up to at
cg3 playing a ready okay so oops no se
Forslund Val I is taking the pawn okay
this is the this is the line that i
actually like for white the only thing
is that it's kind of easy to forget the
theory okay now there is no theory yeah
why this just better at least a little
bit better um okay let's go here the the
thing is that here the night will come
to a 5 which is very annoying for black
mmm maybe I should have played before
earlier anyway so bishops III maybe he
fall I thought 94 he doesn't seem to be
irritated at all he and I kids like it
doesn't really matter what I'm doing
ikea know they probably had to had to
play this so it wasn't there was no big
reason for him to get take a really long
thing do this
so I can not take it so it's close but
anyway if I was good before it's good no
I think I can maybe take but a 22 is
good so dingy five and i'm getting
getting coordination going here and even
if I was good let's do it let's get
those pawns rolling rolling rolling what
you've got time for moves like that I
don't believe this I simply don't and so
what now just f6 I guess and now let's
see i have the check i have have
everything a bishop d5 estrus is
interesting the chick is interesting e 6
is probably also good and hard to say
okay i'll start with the check
so if i take i mean Bishop takes i can
just sec okay it goes back i have 96 now
as at least one possibility night f5
okay if I co night is six you moves the
green I guess Knight a5 threatens made
at least a queen g7 threatening made I
mean you will take you will definitely
take it it's got 93 is somehow look 81
47 is also move maybe do this I mean
it's it's a kind of thing where you
would like to have a moment to to fight
the kill but I have to move at some
point there was some irritating things
okay let's get out of this
okay so night 95 Danielle let's do this
threatening the meydan g73 takes bishop
what okay I'm not meeting you at least
have to pay some attention to threats
okay checkmate yeah yet to take on f5 I
mean I don't known this should be a
winning attack I mean but I didn't
really see see how so what dog is the
engine give here Roxy one is correct and
now King edge one so the the field moves
were correct all right at five okay so I
did the right thing the thing is now he
has to take it's the only move takes and
here i wasn't sure i was actually
thinking taking with the rook could be
something but 93 there's probably an
issue right I don't have something good
there if i take my the queen I can take
and play Bishop before when he has two
check the Queen em clap oops this is
still slightly tricky with this time
probably but other than that I mean that
looked like an extremely strong attack
someone I was really amazed like a five
in a second I mean it's clear that i'm
i'm having this bulldoze attack and a
five and like there is nothing else
that's going on okay Jen d6 yeah this is
also look tempting i get to get the e6
square that seems to win very clearly
come and this isn't actually all that
good tom because because this was
possible
I was actually thinking here I can still
go e6 but there's this reply clap yeah
the engines merciless you know just
taking taking material now okay so 24
wasn't the most precise e6 was clearly
had clearly the choice 96 is good though
yeah this is this is something that I
could have seen actually to take the
Queen threaten made and if you take
stakes with the pawn it's also super
dangerous you have it from here I'm
probably doing it somewhat correctly my
idea was to play wookie 7 or that's a
night movement e7 this kind of thing so
Queen B 6 and we looked at the song yeah
and okay this is has made it the funny
funny made I saw that the idea against a
couple of moves earlier and it still
works they said to try this which is
still complicated at least ok guys
thanks for watching